is somebody gonna get fired no me dizzy  exciting you can't tell from this side  of the room is very serious over here  enough stalling Kristin well that you  feel what you yeah how does that guy say  you blew it fail I'm so sorry  we're behind okay here we go once again  that side of the room no reaction  we think I can see what this is my note  go ahead and I want to do it rock so  badly I really like that one hmm pop is  tired of being told this singing isn't  good enough for frozen to pop is scared  he's gonna get replaced by another pop  named Jack Black it's good don't you  don't you pointy Flint do you have any  suggestions do you have anything good